c'est quoi ce véhicule banner je sais
que c'est toi c'est ta gueule newzbin
non mais c'est très attendu treize
voitures la fia oui oui j'ai annoncé
leur est pas tu connais [ __ ] mais la
leur n'envoyez c'est votre voiture rené
mon chéri vous allez y aller avec votre
voiture parce qu'on a c'est mon beau
fils qui est bien en cours bah oui c'est
votre match finisse quai dans le coup et
on a chopé votre voiture voilée mais
l'ugtt et les [ __ ] les rues on a peur
mais ma voiture pour faire une belle
surprise parce que vous allez mettre le
nez dans le gard elle est dans le
parking navigateur si je vous jure
appelle là tu vas voir vous allez y
allez prenez c'est très simple
rené c'est très simple vous allez aller
récupérer votre véhicule vous allez mais
on va vous cacher les yeux parce qu'il
ya une très grande surprise dont la
voiture dans la voiture il ya une
surprise pour vous et vous allez devoir
mais elle est là votre voiture vous
allez avoir les yeux bandés rené et vous
allez rejoindre votre véhicule dans
votre véhicule vous pourrez retirer le
bandeau puisqu'il est une surprise
derrière d'accord il ya quelqu'un qui va
vous guider pour récupérer un cadeau à
mettre dans le coffre que vous devez
ramener sur ce plateau
mais attention ce un cadeau très fragile
d'accord rené vous êtes prêts
c'est parti relais
rené tu as les relais c'est parti il va
essayer de faire gagner musique se rend
beau t'es con de l'outil fonctions
exceptionnelles
c'est le temps de crohn et par n'est pas
arrivé regardez le temps que ce n'est
pas les allées s'éroder pourtant creux
n'est pas on va revoir toutes les races
rares qu'on a fait à rené cette saison
regarder et après on va le retrouver
dans sa voiture regarde
[Musique]
à déplorer supporters de l'om à l'aise
tu vas devoir porter tout [ __ ] en
pêche
nous
tu vas devoir enfiler ce bonnet paris
saint germain est beau
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit que pour 5 millions est-ce que
j'appuie sur le bouton magique tirer
venise tu prennes s'est mis l'euro sous
les 1 c'est parti
je te les diables tirs - démarche a les
couilles
[Musique]
relis très bien on était content qu'ils
aient gagné l'om gilet brodé rosé frais
rené est prêt tout ce que je veux que
ronnie est ce que roy des montants rené
vous allez pouvoir retirer retirer ce
que vous avez sûrement yeux parce que
regarder vous avez une surprise un hibou
dans la voiture qui va vous guider
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous allez voir on a pris la
voiture de rené c'est son petit nom
aisément les clés et vous allez voir
rené tu vas partir tu vas mettre le
contact
tu vas devoir aller récupérer un cadeau
tu va ramener le cac donnant aux 4,7 à
voiture mais c'est parti rené l'a pas vu
sa voiture en rentrant et c'est parti
rené on y va le magazine relève asie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le cadeau il va revenir
moi je veux voir sa tête quand il va
sortir de la voiture
tralala cette rigolade l'enfant-roi côté
ne sonnera aussi d'exceptionnel alors il
a trouvé le cadeau va aller fait le tour
il est au feu rouge à tokyo regardez les
fans du tour ont sonné
l'actionnaire en ukraine sommeil
attention attention mais va faire à
l'accident ce qu'on va tourner et on
fait mais s'opérerait où la douane
johnny
[Musique]
le permis mais je suis la mosson
merci
voilà ça y est ça y est rené revient
prenez et la cuenca nos doigts
ouais
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est mon match quasi continue
depuis l'abandon
j'ai suivi
suit la menthe orly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
devenu bien écouter entre les bouées au
milieu et le professeur raoult est
exceptionnel allez voir c'est rené rené
aller vite des pistons parce que tu vas
récupérer de cadeaux mon chéri tu as vu
le cadeau optimhome il a alors là que de
ceux qui m'ont mis là c'est pas le voir
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok alors opéré mais oui les godets
renaît ouais c'est beau tu as gagné tu
as fait gagner à tout public le donne à
ta belle tout le public
well as tu me rappelles aventure tu vois
que tu es trop bossé d'affaires emporté
à tout public virtuel le superbe des
coûts et de multifonctions
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel c'est bon c'est bon tu en
gagnes tu ris ques gérer mais est ce
assez pour toi un cadeau mais nous dans
le coffre c'est pour toi je te l'offre
il a pas compris et tu repars avec le
sosie du professeur avoue juste lui tu
m'as mis la géniale
[Applaudissements]